[Music]
is immigration a problem that
politicians are choosing to avoid that's
what R shrier thinks who has written
about the figures for her magazine
column this week she joins me now along
with demographer and author of the 8
billion Jennifer d
scuber l I'll start with you first uh
you write in this week's magazine about
last week's uh net migration fig and a
certain sense of fatalism from the
public towards them explain your
argument as you set out in this week's
spectator well if you look at the polls
in both the United States and the UK uh
there's a lot of popular pressure for
reduced immigration that it's going it's
too much too fast and nobody asked the
people who actually live in these
countries uh whether they were
interested in a mass redesign of their
population um and yet there seem to be
no political parties of uh big enough to
matter uh who are seriously devoted to
uh clamping down on the quantity and the
rapidity of uh incomers in both our
countries and uh it's it it makes people
angry uh but it also uh makes them feel
imp and I I'm afraid that in this column
I confess to the fact that I have become
unhealthily addicted to reading the
comments after articles about
immigration in a whole range of papers
and one of the most interesting things
about that sampling is that the same
rage plus
impotence uh in these comments is not
only where you would expect them in the
telegraph you know or The Spectator um
but uh and in the Wall Street Journal of
course but even in the New York Times
and that's shocking and New Yorkers have
had a real taste of uh immigration close
up because New York is now inundated
with uh what New York thinks is a lot of
immigrants and what the Border
communities think is a drop in the
bucket uh Jennifer I mean you know
there's no doubt these figures that came
out last week and last two years have
been you extraordinary numbers for the
UK to take you know 700 600,000 or so
what do you make of liel's peace and
what's your attitude generally to mass
migration of the kind we've seen in
recent
years yeah you know the thing about
these liberal democracies that we live
in and liberal meaning just you know
we're supposed to be giving people the
the right to speak up here is that we
are not going to see any big change in
Immigration policy because there's
pressures on both the right and the left
for openness and there's pressures on
both the right and the left for Clos Ure
so I think the heart of Lionel's piece
saying we're stuck and we're not seeing
any change the politicians are stuck the
people are stuck it is absolutely true
but it's baked into the system and so
that's where as a political scientist
with that hat on I see that it's been
that way for decades and decades and it
will be that way in the future a lot of
what I do is talk to businesses and
governments about you know what will the
future of demogra demographics be like
and what will the future of policy be
like and my answer with immigration is
it will be exactly the same because the
way these systems are designed it
doesn't allow for uh really rational
policy and in fact democracy itself
really encourages catering to Niche
interests and Catering to fear and
there's always a lot of fear around
demographic
change LEL I mean do you think that the
reasons politicians aren't addressing it
how much is it to do with sort of a lack
of uh initiative a lack of desire to to
talk about this I mean this morning I
was watching the home Affairs select
committee here in westmin
and it was extraordinary that the fact
that some of the top civil servants for
instance didn't know the figures about
how many people were arriving being
detained being deported Etc after their
Asylum claims failed is it about a lack
of political will or is it simply we
just don't have the technical
capabilities to follow on that desire to
try and stop the population
rise I I mean I I submit in my column
that uh most politicians don't know how
to stop immigration even if they wanted
to in a lot of instances they don't care
enough to want to but they're
fundamentally factless and uh you know
there are especially in the UK uh and
Europe generally huge legal barriers to
enforcing your own borders and they just
strike everyone is insurmountable and uh
it's like oh I'm sorry the the
helplessness that I detect in those
comment threads I also detect in
politicians they don't know what to do
they don't know how to do it it would be
hard and I'm I'm not sure I accept the
fatalistic position that this is just
going to keep happening and there's
nothing to do but in order to do
something it it would take enormous
political will it would take a lot of
political change it would in the UK it
would take a compl complete
transformation of the Civil Service of
the home office which basically regards
itself as you know Britain's Open Door
uh and and that's that's where that's
where my fatalism kicks in I don't see
that happening I I don't see politicians
really reversing themselves and making
the sacrifices and taking the political
risks that would be required to at least
narrow that open door there are
countries in the world who have very
strict immigration policies and uh
granted they take uh a demographic hit
it means that they have older
populations I'm you know talk about for
example Japan uh but it's worth it to
them they have decided that they would
rather uh have a shrinking population
and a coherent one uh rather than
introduce the kind of
atomization and conflict that we have
accepted in the rest to the
West yes I mean Jennifer I mean Ral D
touches on the point about you know
social cohesion and that seems to be a
real sort of the real s Nu of the issue
here which is that people don't feel as
though perhaps immigration is being
something done to them in their
communities are there any kind of policy
solutions for policy makers to look at
when doing this and and is there a
possibility of the case that as LEL says
you know migration is an issue certainly
of increased political salience here is
there a way of making perhaps
immigration more popular Mass
immigration more popular among
in countries which are experiencing a
lot of it uh if it's a matter of you
know better policy Solutions or will
people always be hostile to large
numbers of people arriving uh if there's
a sense perhaps that they're not being
catered
to yeah I think the problem that all the
politicians take is that they're looking
for big splashy reforms and those will
never pass and and that's the case
across many policy areas we see it I
talk a lot about retirement policies
it's you know big things like macron
trying to raise retirement age to
actually make an impact you don't have
to do the big things that will never
pass you do smaller things but the
smaller things are not sexy and you're
not rewarded for that with votes uh
there are so many ways to ease the
perception of quote unquote takeover by
immigration because honestly at the end
of the day the numbers are interesting
but it's perception that matters the
most it's how you feel and you you know
I remember 20 years ago looking at some
of the the numbers of migration into
Europe that were much smaller but the
perception and the feeling and the
rhetoric and the debate sounded exactly
the same so we you have to start moving
into nitty-gritty policies like do you
have enough resources in local schools
to help with uh non-english-speaking
students who are being put into
classrooms so that the community feels
like their children are supported and
the new incomer children are supported
as well well nobody wants to run on that
platform that's boring you want to do
something that really tries to you know
cater to specific voting groups so yes
there are so many policies that can be
done in the US our Asylum adjudication
system is incredibly underfunded and
understaffed well that's a boring thing
for a politician to talk about fixing
even though you would think both the
left and the right would have a vested
interest in fixing that system so I
think we're really stuck until we have
politicians who are not putting first
their own re-election and instead are
thinking about how to actually make the
system work for
everyone l i was want to ask you I mean
you obviously in your column to talk
mostly about that kind of shared sense
of fatalism and particularly between uh
the UK and the us but I just wondered in
terms of the immigration debate and mass
migration what are the differences
between the two countries in terms of
you know obviously there's you the issue
around you the UK being an island as
opposed to having a large land mass with
Mexico for instance but what do you say
of the kind of similarities and contrast
between the two nations in their
migration approach
well one of the big differences is uh
religion because uh and and that's a
another spanner in the works emotionally
and
culturally uh because the UK has a much
higher immigration rate of of of Muslims
uh whereas in the US basically they're
coming from everywhere uh but especially
from Latin America increasingly from
India and even from China uh the Chinese
are coming up through the southern
border which
is really
surprising um China's a long way away um
I would say they share the same
fecklessness a complete operational
failure uh and and also they share a a
political relationship to immigration
because uh you know the so-called Elite
is very big on
multiculturalism and um and basically
believes in open borders W which is not
the case with the population so you've
you've got uh people in charge who are
completely at odds with the with their
with their populace and at the same time
um you you've got massive operational
failure uh in inability to deal with the
numbers um
and I guess the biggest contrast between
the two is that in the
UK the the problem if you look at as it
as a problem is legal immigration and
whereas in the US it's mostly illegal
immigration and to the tune of of
millions of people per year um the the
Biden Administration has probably led in
about 8 million people and that is uh
even in a in a nation of
330 million people that's that's
starting to change the nature of your
population in a tiny period of
time there's another difference if May
if I may with the the us as well just to
add on to that and that's our two-party
system because even though you might
have segments of the population that are
are very um upset about the current
immigration levels or the nature of that
immigration the way the system is right
now the levels and numbers it works for
the politicians they do not face a
penalty for what is happening and that's
because we just have these two big
groups so when we look at polls yes
people might as as Lionel mentions in
her column people might say that they
want lower immigration but when you
start asking them to rank the issues
that they care the most about you start
asking them about the salience of that
issue for them and what really gets them
to turn up to vote immigration starts to
move down the list so that means nobody
has to actually do anything there's a
there'll be a lot of talk about it in
all of the debates it'll be all over the
media but they won't actually face an
electoral penalty for doing nothing uh
some political scientists have called it
talk tough and do nothing because you
don't have to and so that's where we
start to see some really big differences
between uh the United States two-party
system and then some of the Continental
European systems that have multiple
parties and that's why you see some of
those parties starting to gain more
electoral victories on an
anti-immigration platform and that is
because there are more of them to choose
from I'd say there there is also one
other big difference and that's
Trump right the UK doesn't have a trump
and um you know the the immigration is
moving up voters list of concerns I know
in the UK it's now number three and
that's counting everybody including all
those labor voters and green voters it
still gets to number three uh and uh I
don't actually know the rankings for the
us right now but it is a huge factor in
Trump's popularity and he is the only
politician who is appreciably talking
about uh Mass immigration and wanting to
stop it and by the way I say this as
someone who does not support Trump never
has and dreads another Trump presidency
but those pictures of the board order
these tens of thousands of people moving
across uh shallow areas of the Rio Grand
beinged by the border control being put
into buses and shipped all over the
country with virtually no paperwork and
and theoretical appointments with
immigration judges literally years from
now those pictures are politically
Dynamite thank you Jennifer and thank
you Lionel
[Music]